last year when chat GPT first came out
and we're at vental ml we were all very
excited about what it can do uh but the
the same time we were worried that such
powerful technology is in only in the
hands of a few uh but then we think to
ourselves that if LMS follow the path of
any previous open- Source software that
we know uh such as operating systems and
uh uh relational database then in just a
matter of a few years there could be
really compelling really containing
contenders coming out from the open
source to challenge his position but we
were completely wrong but in the sense
of that it didn't take a few years it
only took a few months back in February
this year uh meta released the first
version of llama for research purposes
uh his weights got leaked in shortly uh
one week after the release but in the
hindsight this is something like a
blessing in disguise because it inspired
a sequence of models such as aleka and
lunia to build on top of Lama for more
Innovation and well remember MPT for its
large contact size at the time and uh
Falcon as model briefly took over uh the
best model over surpasses llama as a b
best model briefly and then starting uh
July this year when Lama 2 releases this
time was a chat model of different sizes
then the cycle just repeats again I
think what we learned from this is that
the open source llms are innovating
really fast and the capability is
getting better and
better as opposed to advance the slides
yeah so it's it's capabilities advancing
better and better uh two we we all want
to be able to leverage these uh uh llms
in production however to leverage to to
use this llm production is not as easy
as just downloading the model to your
laptop and starting it locally you won't
be able to get the efficiency and the
performance that you need in a
production setting and that brings us to
our topic today is how to productionize
open source llms and I am Sean I'm from
bent M um I'm actually based in
California it's h 4:30 almost 5 in the
morning when I take the time slot I
didn't realize this the time zone was in
UTC so I get something to learn but I'm
overall very excited to be here to share
with you our experience uh building
productionizing uh open source
llms so from our perspective there are
three reasons that you want to run llms
in production it's Control Data privacy
and cost efficiency so before diving
into any of these we'll first look at
factuality factuality is very important
it's the opposite of hallucination which
we're all very familiar and it's one of
the biggest problems that llms are
combating because it leads to misleading
information incorrect answers and we we
an LM is not useful when it hallucinates
so how well do op Source llms perform in
terms of factuality and this study came
out a few months ago by any scale it's
comparing um summarization accuracy of
Lama 70 billion versus GPD 4 and it's
using a multiple choice of format of
answer to pick the the right right
answer of summarization I won't get into
the details but the gist of it is that
human performance at 84% gp4 all
performs human at
85.5 Lama 70 billion model is not that
far behind is at
81.7% accuracy all in all this is a
single example it doesn't represent the
full picture but it gets us uh an
understanding that open source models
are getting there are getting closer to
the Preparatory ones and uh uh factually
I think if we use them in the right way
we can really extract a lot of value out
of them so with that out of the way
let's talk about the First Advantage is
control so control is in the form of
fine-tuning the model in the uh and
managing the format of the output
exactly in the way that you want uh you
can either do a full parameter fine tune
or do a low rank adaptation more well
known as Laura to finding a model you
actually don't know a whole lot of data
a few hundred records will do and a
handful hours of GP running on GPU will
get you a pretty good results um if you
don't feel like fine-tuning your own
model you can use pre-trained model
that's available on hugging face
currently uh there are over 36,000 text
generation models and it's increasing at
a very rapid Pace I think a month or two
ago I was looking at it was only at
22,000 so increased by 30 30% or so in
just a matter of a few
months and when should you be
fine-tuning your model and to answer
this question we look at three case
studies um the first one is a functional
representation which translates natural
language into function calls you can
think of a like converting uh
instruction into into a into a function
call the second is a SQL generation
which also from natural language
converting to a SQL SQL statement
against a very specific schema the last
one is gsm AK which these are uh gr
School uh word problems which requires
more context and reasoning and we have
uh we're evaluting four different models
in here the red uh model is Lama 70
billion green is 13 billion the blue is
70 billion and the pink bar is gbd4 and
within the uh the the Llama models you
can see different shades of the color so
at the very bottom is the performance
the darkest shade represents the
performance of the model when it's not
fine tuned so we're strictly talking
about the Baseline model the second
darker shade represents when the is
fine-tuned using Laura so you can see
that the performance gets a lot better
and the lightest shade represents the
full parameter performance so the
takeaway here is that fine-tuned models
perform much better than the Baseline
model the Baseline model is barely
getting anything accurate but fine tun
model getting close to 100% at least for
the first and second
tasks and what's interesting is that
these models outperform GPD 4 uh in in
terms of accuracy as well when it comes
to first and second case the functional
represent representation and the SQL
generation case however when we need a
lot of reasoning in the problem solving
space These Fine tun models do not even
get closer to gp4 so when should you be
fine-tuning a model I guess the answer
for now is that when the reasoning task
the the task require low reasoning F two
model performs pretty well all performs
gd4 even with a smaller parameter
sizes that brings us to the next
Advantage with data privacy so our users
uh in our open source Community come and
ask us for help to deploy their models
uh open source models for them um they
worry that calling a third party API
will lead to leakage of their sensitive
in sensitive data information they worry
that their data will be used in training
the Next Generation next iteration of
llms as a result you know sensitive
information is exposed uh where running
open source model you the model is well
within your virtual private Cloud so
your data will never leave your network
boundary so you know that your data will
not be used for other purposes um
transparent also um transparent training
data is usually comes as a part of the
open source model itself you can also
disclose that to your stakeholders and
your clients so you not worried getting
into potentially I guess copyright
infringement problem uh lastly if you
run your own model you're taking control
of the availability so you're not
susceptible to the provider
outages um the third Advantage we see is
cost efficiency so commercial LMS we all
know charge by tokens and contact sizes
uh GPD for Char is8 8,000 tokens and if
you want larger contact sizes doubles
the cost and running fine tune models is
still up to six times more of the
Baseline model cost and the cost can
really add up if you're running agent
based application or chat based
applications where there are multiple
rounds of iterations that goes between
your application and the and the model
server however if you run uh for uh you
run with open source LMS you only pay
for the hardware that you know you incur
you pay for the gpus basically and there
is no extra cost for running fine tune
model if you uh your traffic can
saturate at a single GPU a single VM uh
I think cost efficiency aspect can uh be
much F favorable situation compared to
calling a third party API uh what one
very important aspect is that you can
choose to run much smaller parameter
size the llns not all problems requires
the GPT 4 to solve as we've seen
previously Lama 7B and 13B once they're
fine-tuned they Sol they get pretty
accurate and they even outperform gp4 so
with smaller tasks smaller models uh you
can potentially gain additional cost
efficiency but as we talk about
previously there are challenges that
running these models in production and
we see that there are five different uh
aspects operability scalability
throughput latency and all of these
eventually contributes to cost which is
answer the question how much do I need
to spend for running this llms so first
let's talk about operability uh llms are
called large language models because
they have large number of parameters and
each of the parameter is uh represented
typically as a floating Point 16bit data
type on GPU or 32bit on CPU and to
calculate the memory footprint you can
simply multiply the parameter size by
two in terms of gigabytes of memory
needed uh because uh each each parameter
is requir two bytes to load into GPU
memory so what what we can see is that
uh Lama 70 70 billion model will require
140 gigabyt of GPU memory to serve that
simply exceeds a100 even with the 80
gigabyte version of the GPU device so we
cannot easily fit a model on a single
GPU card uh additionally fitting the
model weights on in the GPU memory is
not what you is is just a scratch the
bare minimum of the uh requirements for
GPU memory you also need to reserve
enough GPU memory for running inference
actually ideally more than the model
weights itself so that's the first
challenge operability second is
scalability as we all know GPU today is
still very scarce and they're expensive
uh you want to pick the right GPU type
for running your inference if you're
running smaller models ideally you would
uh deploy onto fractional gpus and if
you're running mult larger models as
we've seen previously we want to run the
multiple GPU devices with traffic
scaling up and down you want to uh scale
the instance up and down with the
traffic and if there is no traffic you
ideally want to scale to zero to
conserve your cost uh utilizing spot
instances can be a trick uh for CPU
serving because gpus is really hard to
come by light along the spot instances
but this comes with the challenge that
you want to be able to dynamically load
and unload model with the and serve the
model on the instance with a best
availability uh C start is a problem
that we commonly see because these
models are are very large and streaming
those models from the model repository
down to the machine takes a very long
time just because the sheer size of the
model and co-art also comes in the form
of that you need to wait for the cloud
provider to uh provision you a de
provision you an instance and waiting
for that instance to join your cluster
we talk about container image download
and model downloading takes a very long
time uh then we still need to load the
the the weights
into CPU memory and GPU memory all of
that takes a very long time and this uh
will require a lot of optimization to
solve and accelerate the co-star delay
the third problem is throughput so
throughput is typically measured by
token per second and uh as English
language each token roughly represent s
word in English for other languages the
the ratio varies it depends on the
tokenizer that you choose to
use uh the tradition tradition in the
traditional ml settings the way to
improve throughput is to use this
technique called batching however
batching in uh lln is very complex and
inefficient if you just take it at a
static way uh because LM Don't just run
iteration once it runs multiple times
every time it generates a token it runs
it one round of iteration and that's why
when we use chbt or others types of LMS
you see words appear on screen word by
word because LM is running
iteration one at a time and the length
of the generation is undetermined at at
the beginning we don't know so that we
have to reserve the maximum amount of
memory possible and to add on top of
that once a sequence has finished
generating we cannot return it back
unless the host bat is complete so in
this case we see on screen sequence
three cannot be returned even though if
finished generation right away until
sequence 2 has completed so all of these
uh in the traditional batching sense as
a complexity for batching for llms we'll
talk about potential Improvement uh in
how we can accelerate throughput in llm
using better batching techniques lastly
is latency latency is easy to understand
as a challenge uh there are two types as
in the llm settings you can think
there's a perceived latency uh this is
applicable when you're consumer is a
human being so for example like a
chatbot uh all we need to do is exceed
the average reading speed of a human
it's roughly five tokens per second as
long as we exceed that the perceived
latency gets very low even though the it
takes longer time to generate the the
full body of taex end to end the next
type of latency is more is end to end
latency and this is more applicable if
the consumer is a program so such as an
LM agent because the agents needs the
full text to be able to move on to the
next text so uh even with streaming for
example the streaming the token back to
the LM we're not going to solve the the
endtoend latency
problem so at been to ml we are a uh
open- Source unified AI application
framework we are here we want to help uh
teams in the world machine learning
teams in the world uh deploy all kinds
of models including llms and by looking
at this framework we first have to
Define what an AI application is uh try
to think of think of the way that you
want to build chat GPT but with open-
Source models where you can provide the
chat bot with an image that you took for
example in your living room uh and you
want to ask the chatbot for assistance
to replace a certain object or change
the color of the wall and for this
application to work you need a a
sequence of model to work in conjunction
to complete this task first first of all
you need an llm to understand the user
intention and then generate responses
and then you need a a set of uh uh image
generation and models such as
segmentation model which able to carve
out the different objects on the screen
on in the picture a clip model to
understand what the different objects
are and the text to image model such as
stable diffusion to replace a certain
object with a with a different one and
to be able to support this model this
architecture uh of running multiple
models in the same application VL come
up with this architecture that uh works
with different model Runners so model
Runners you can think of it as a uh
abstraction of model that can run an
independent
hardware and scales independently based
on traffic so an llm is probably running
on like a like a a more powerful GPU but
uh image segmentation can probably run
on a weaker GPU uh this way you can get
Best Hardware utilization at the same
time cost efficiency out of it and we
have an API server layer that
orchestrates the traffic and request to
the different uh backend model inference
and orchestrates the uh calls and
responses back to the user at the same
time bent ml packages dependency
environment source code model and
configuration
in the same distributable uh artifact
call it a bental so that you can achieve
consistent Behavior between development
time and production so what you see in
the development time is actually what
you get in production as a that's a
proposition of this architecture but as
we've seen before um just by solving the
mlops problems solving be able to deploy
the model does not we still have the set
of challenges with llms and that's why
we built um that's why we built the uh
another project open Allon to to help
deploy uh and facilitate deploy and
operate LMS in production and we'll look
at what what open LM is at the simplest
form it's a uh can start be started as a
service with a single command line by
providing the architecture in this case
llama and the model ID we here we have a
Lama 27 billion chat
model uh we can see this in action when
it's run it Expos an HTP Point uh we can
provide it with a prompt in this case
we're asking with concept of time and we
together we provide a set of Lon configs
and we can see the response generating
Back In The Stream fashion fashion in uh
real
time so beside uh running as an HTTP
server open Allen can also uh Pro on in
the HP server it also expose open AI
compatible endpoints what this means is
that if you already written an open AI
uh application using open a clients all
you need to change is the base URL from
an open AI URL to the open deployment
URL you don't need to provide API key
because we're using open source model
here none of the other uh code needs to
change and it should just function the
API is fully compatible with open AI it
also can be exposed as a python Library
so can import open LM as an LM object we
can run generate iterator in async Loop
so we get all the generated text back
iteratively uh openal integrates with
Lang chain as an LM object so if you
have uh L chain application you can
replace any llm objects with open llm
same for Lama index the integration is
is native you can replace any llms L
index with open L implementation
and at the end of course open works with
Bento ml we'll dive a little bit de
deeper at the end of this service file
if have time at the end so after seeing
what open LM can do why do we want to
use open LM the first benefit comes in
the in the comes in in the wide range of
uh models that it supports so all the
latest and greatest models architectures
you can pretty much expect is supported
within op open LM is itself and to use
it you can just you only need to provide
the the arguments with a model ID and
the model architecture in this example
I'm only showing the command line uh
arguments but you can think about the
python SDK access with the L chain and
with the Lama index works the s in a
similar way but with python code the
second Advantage is quantization so we
saw how large language model take a
whole lot of GPU memory to run uh
because we are using floating 16 bit uh
data type to represent its weight but
there techniques their quantization
Frameworks that can reduce the the model
ways to uh three bits four bits uh with
lower precision and we can comfortably
fit a llama 70 billion model under 40
gigabytes of uh uh GPU memory that means
we can run llama 70 billion in a single
a100 GPU and that that's pretty huge and
uh we with with a a 80 gigabyte model we
can save comfortable enough uh GPU
Headroom for running inference as well
and to be able to use the uh the the
quantization framework you just have to
pass in the quantize parameter in this
case we can use
gpdq um next we talk about the
traditional static batching wasn't the
best fit for llms that brings us to
continuous batching continuous batching
allow us to asynchronously schedule the
newly arrived request into the batch
without having to wait for the previous
batch to complete so in this case we can
see as soon as S3 the SE the uh sequence
3 finishes we can schedule sequence five
to run without having to wait for
sequence two to complete and this is all
thank to uh our collaboration and
integration with VM VM uh integrates
builds the continuous batching and Page
attention which a more efficient use of
memory by default and the open LM comes
with vlm support out of the box for if
if there's a GPU
available the next optimization is model
parallelism uh this is the practice to
fit a very large model onto multiple GPU
devices you can do this either through
pipeline parallelism parallelism which
is split by layers or tensor parallelism
split split the weights within each
layers uh Worth to point out that model
parallelism introduce additional uh
communication overhead because you're
multiple devices needs to talk to each
other which ultimately impacts your
performance but this is uh useful when
you want to run a large model without
quantization and to to run them on
multiple cars is the only way and to
support that you can pass the worker per
resource the value is the inverse of the
number of cars that you want to run 0.25
means you're running this model of four
devices lastly is token streaming so
what it means is that we'll return the
token back to the user as soon as it
becomes ready and this help perceive
latency because you know user can
consume the data right away uh for when
the consumer is a human and this is
built out of the built in out of the box
with the stream uh generate stream
endpoint um with all of that said this
famous paper came from Google back in
2015 says that uh the ml code for
running uh inference is only a small
part of the huge ecosystem of mlops we
still need to solve all the challenges
that comes in the form of mlops but
luckily open Lon built with bentto ML
which comes with the best practi is
built-in so bent ml is fully
customizable with python therefore
integrates with all the python ecosystem
and tools all the uh just with in a
python way and uh a pack as we mentioned
before VL packages the model source code
configuration as a bental art artifact
so we can achieve achieve a consist
Behavior between development time and
production time with the bentos uh we
can we can uh do virgin control with the
uh Bento store support and Bento ml
comes with observability out of the box
so you don't have to implement metrics
tracing and logs it automatically has
established as part of the framework and
the bentos can be containerized into
standardized oci compliant images so you
can deploy that to any platform that
supports uh image and container
deployments means pretty much all the
public clouds with kubernetes and Docker
support um how are we doing on time uh
three minutes maybe let's quickly dive
into the architecture and uh how the
service code looks like so quick
reminder this is architecture we have
you know different model Runners uh an
API server so with open llm uh the llm
can be imported into bent ml as a rner
and the runner can be uh established
part of the service that we see in line
six line four and line six and in the
API definition which this will be later
exposed at HTV endpoint uh user can
Define developer can Define any Behavior
using that uh llm end points so in this
very simple case we're just passing in
the input text as a prompt to the llm
and return to result back to the user
but you can imagine if we're building a
chatbot where we are uh we need to
understand the intent and maybe call a
second model within the API we can all
do that because it's just simple python
code uh once we build this have this
service we can run Bento ml build this
is how we get a Bento from what we've
seen previously and you can run Bento ml
list we see all the Bento that you have
stored locally and the bentos can be
pushed through remote location as well
similar to you know how we manage Docker
images okay I think we're right about
time let's conclude um so today talked
about advantages of using open source
llms uh then we dived deeper into the
challenges of deploying these open
source LM production and at the end we
talk about how bent ML and open LM can
the optimization builing in there can
help us solve these problems and uh
thank you uh thank you for your time and
thank you for P for giving us this
opportunity so I what's on screen is my
personal LinkedIn and the GitHub page
for bonl and open LM these are fully
open source project with a Pachi 2
license you can use it for your purpose
um yeah thank you